[Music]
criminals wanting to get their hands on
your stimulus money have resulted in
unprecedented scams from phony phone
calls tax even fake checks
all related to your stimulus money
kirsten joyce is on your side with tips
to avoid having your money getting into
the wrong hands
brian the ftc has received more than 340
000 reports of fraud relating to
coronavirus costing victims more than
320 million dollars to date
socialcatfish.com released the top
stimulus check scams and tips on how to
avoid them based on information it
gathered from the ftc
fbi and the irs now the first is a
robocall check scam and a person will be
calling pretending to be the irs asking
for your personal financial information
they'll claim they need it to deposit
the check into your account
do not give out personal information
scammers claiming they are from the
government may email you
tell you to click on a link to verify
information
or send a text message for a link to
fill out an application to receive your
check
do not click on any links that you don't
recognize
if you click on a suspicious link
they'll likely take you to a fake
website that can steal your information
so there are no
non-government websites giving stimulus
checks
and finally scammers have been mailing
fake checks that look exactly like the
official government-issued paper
stimulus checks
somebody calls you and says hey um
either we've sent you a check or we're
sending you a check
and once once you deposit it they say it
was for too much and we need the money
back or we're gonna
you know you know get it back and so
they have you send them you know the
overage which you know hundred dollars
couple hundred dollars couple thousand
dollars depending what it is
and you you paying that money the check
bounces and then you get in trouble
from your bank for depositing a bad
check so have your bank verify it
david mcclellan is the president of the
website socialcatfish.com he says you
can use a site like his to verify all
the information as these claims
and scams do evolve over time and if you
encounter a scam contact local law
enforcement or file a complaint with the
ftc
for more information on the status of
your check you can also visit the irs
website